well joining us now is the MP for Don
Valley a constituency which includes
Connors fur and it's castle which is
your just saw just that and thanks being
with us thank you for going to Connors
room stepping outside the town center
it's always good to break out into a
different towns as well as the kind of
cities or the bigger towns of tend to go
to and when I went to Connors breath and
don't cost to as well and the thing that
kept coming up again and again for a
reason why people voted to leave was
immigration only is that your experience
I think it was a major factor and not
just in the referendum I think this has
been brewing for a decade or more
people's concern about how immigration
is managed I think there are some
employers who have exploited the free
movement rules to for example through
agencies wholesale recruit people to
work in local firms and I think this
generally sort of these themes of
concerns have been you know pushed to
one side and it's not that my
constituents are against all immigration
that's not the case I've done my own
surveys and have found that to be the
case and I think that's mirrored
nationally as well I think there's a
very small minority people who don't
want any immigration at all but they do
want to feel we have a fair and manage
migration system and in some ways Sophie
I suppose the referendum you know
created the bubble if you like in which
that particular issue was a given voice
you've spoken before about your
constituents being insulted by other
politicians yes I mean do you think that
some MPs perhaps leave a labor imputes
as well from London from some of the
bigger cities don't really understand
your constituents concerns look down
than perhaps I don't think they
understand them and I think their choice
of words is patronizing and I have to
say on a on occasion offensive I mean
even on social media I mean I never go
out on social media to troll people but
whenever I've stood up for the people
that I represent and not just in in
Doncaster but you know let's remember
every region in England outside of
London voted leave and their voice you
immediately get trolled and shut down
and some of the language that is used by
some politicians and some involved in
the people's vote campaign and some of
these others who want to overturn the
referendum is patronizing it's saint
language oh well you know you know
uneducated
ill informed you didn't know what they
didn't know what they were voting for
they didn't know that it meant this that
and the other I mean the truth is
actually I think people did have an
understanding about the consequences
they knew that it would be seismic in
terms of our country and all of that was
put forward by the remain campaigners
including myself Sophie because I
campaign for remain in my own
constituency but the truth is people
felt that they wanted to be outside the
EU they definitely wanted to feel like
every other major country outside the EU
they wanted more control over
immigration and for my part I feel that
we need to get a deal we need to get a
reasonable deal so that we don't crash
out without one because I think that
would be detrimental and I'm talking
about the No Deal scenario that mmm and
saying that would be detrimental to your
constituents does that mean that you can
envisage a scenario where you could
support a deal that Tereza may came back
with even if the labor policy was to
vote against well look i hope that labor
has put a reasonable deal and and
looking at Labour's six tests on for
example that we should have protection
for workers rights the environment and
other matters i think most of those a
reasonable deal would tick those boxes
but it's not about it's not about
supporting teresa may it's supporting
what I said in the general election just
over a year ago I promised to respect
the vote in 2016 to support the best
deal for Doncaster but also to not
support a second referendum so what I'm
looking for in all of this is a
reasonable deal and the problem is we
are now those of us who want to get a
deal are sometimes stuck between a rock
and a hard place between hardline brexit
ears who think we can worse off without
a deal and I'm afraid also some hardline
remainders who for their own reasons
don't want to deal because they want to
overturn the referendum result so if the
RUF offer that we think Teresa may is
proposing at the minute
was on the table which is effectively
checkers a backstop involving keeping
the UK in the customs union is that
something you could support well forgive
me if I hold myself until I see the
final deal because I have to say we've
had so many summits where we've been let
left you know led up the hill and things
haven't happened but yeah do you know
what if we have something the
ensures that we can have a close
relationship with a single market a
customs of arrangement that we obviously
have protections in terms of EU
nationals that are here but also Brits
in other parts of the EU that during the
transition and don't forget Sophie I
mean I don't think labor has taken
enough credit for some of the positive
changes that have occurred in the last
two years
I mean Kier was arguing for a transition
period two years ago he's argued for
better protection of EU nationals and
has talked about workers rights in the
environment and taking on a lot of the
EU regulation into our own legal
framework we have actually won many of
those demands so I feel that if the deal
that comes back which will have to have
the support of the other 27 EU members I
think of a deal like that comes back it
cannot be called a hard brexit and I
would have to very much way up what my
decision is and to be honest if it's a
reasonable deal that meets all those
requirements that I've put forward to
support a deal then I think I would so
there are reports that you know up to 30
Labour MPs could end up supporting this
sort of deal that you described do you
think that's roughly accurate I'm really
not sure but I think if a reasonable
deal is on the table the question I
think you know for some of my labour
colleagues is why wouldn't you support a
deal why would you why would you stand
along Boris Johnson or Jacob Riis MOG he
wants us to crash out without a deal and
that's the choice before it behind us so
if there was a vote of no-confidence in
Parliament in this government and you
would talk about universal credit
earlier on on the program I would be
there Jeremy Corbyn and other colleagues
voting for a photo of a girl confidence
against the government but this isn't
about a vote of confidence this is about
whether we crash out of the EU without a
deal and I really don't think that
serves the public's interest and I don't
think it serves Labour's interests to be
seen to be doing that but it's got to be
the right deal and that's why we've got
to make sure that we those of us who
want a deal you know actually push for
that and don't allow the no dealers to
take control okay Carolyn thank you very
much thank you